Now let's talk about
an alternative model for
structuring server applications
that perform concurrent processing.
The model we'll talk about is
called event-driven model.
An event-driven application can
be characterized as follows.
The application is implemented
in a single address space,
there is basically
only a single process.
And a single thread of control.
Here is the illustration
of this model and
this is taken from the read
pies flash paper as well.
The main part of the process is
the event dispatcher that continuously
in a loop looks for incoming events and
then based on those events invokes one
or more of the registered handlers.
Here events correspond to
some of the following things.
We see that the request
from the client browsers,
that message that's received from
the network, that's an event.
Completion of the send, so once the
server responds to the client request,
the fact that the send completed,
that's another event,
as far as the system is concerned.
Completion of a disk read operation.
That's another event that the system
will need to know how to handle.
The dispatcher has the ability to accept
any of these types of notifications,
and then based on the notification type
to invoke the appropriate handler.
So in that sense, it operates
very much like a state machine.
Since we're talking about
a single credit process,
invoking a handler simply means that we
will jump to the appropriate location in
the processes address space where
the handler is implemented.
At that point the handler
execution can start.
For instance, if the process is notified
that there is a pending connection
request on the network
port that it uses,
the dispatcher will pass that event
to the accept connection handler.
If the event is a receipt
of a data of message on
an already established connection,
then the event dispatcher will pass
that to the read request handler.
Once the filename is extracted from the
request and it's confirmed that the file
is present, the process will
send out chunks of the file.
And then once there is a confirmation
that that chunk of the file portion of
the file has been successfully sent and
it will continue
iterating over the handler that's
dealing with the send operation.
If the file is not there,
then some sort of error message
will be sent to the client.
So whenever an event occurs the handlers
are the sequence of code that executes
in response to these events.
The key feature of the handlers
is that they run to completion.
If a handler needs to
perform a blocking operation,
it will initiate the blocking operation
and then it will immediately pass
control back to the event dispatcher,
so it will no longer be in the handler.
At that point, the dispatcher is
free to service other events or
call other handlers.